bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
lundi une filiale d'alstom condamné à
une amende record de dix mille euros par
salarié pour avoir exposé son personnel
à l'amiante un jugement accueilli par
des applaudissements et qui pourrait
faire jurisprudence
la rentrée des classes s'est déroulée
sans accroc majeur pour 12 millions 400
mille élèves l'école privée affiche
encore complet 25 mille demandes restent
non satisfaites
le géant des airs l'airbus a380 a
effectué son premier vol avec des
passagers des employés d'airbus tous
volontaires
ils se disent impressionnés par l'espace
et le silence dans l'avion avec nous en
duplex de toulouse le chef pilote
jacques roset qui était aux commandes
face à l'envolée des prix du pétrole la
france renoue avec son charbon une mine
à ciel ouvert sera exploité dans la
nièvre
le projet provoque une levée de
boucliers des riverains il y aura bien
une présence arabe au sein de la finul
la force de l'onu au liban le qatar
annonce l'envoi de 200 à 300 soldats
côté français les chars leclerc ont pris
la route pour aller embarqué à toulon
enfin jean reno de retour au théâtre
pour une pièce sur les relations d'un
couple divorcé les grandes occasions
jean reno qui est notre invité pour ce
soir et à jean laville